is there an app that can delete copies
slash multiples of photos on my
smartphone i have so many literally
thousands and it's just way too time
consuming to review them all to find and
delete the redundancies so i have a few
best practices that i use here so number
one is i have a trigger to go into my
camera roll
anytime i hop on a flight now you and i
we fly more than your average person so
it doesn't that doesn't have to be your
trigger but what can be your trigger
maybe it's every every time you go to
the dmv or the doctor's office the
anytime you're waiting in line somewhere
maybe it's any time you go to chipotle
and you have to wait in that long line
yeah i just go through my most recent
photos and delete anything that i don't
want there anymore now if i do that
enough if we're flying enough for
example then i have very little work to
do before the plane even takes off i've
gone through and deleted everything i
want to delete
now during the pandemic it didn't fly at
all and so last time i hopped on a plane
it was like oh man i'm going to be
spending this whole flight deleting some
photos and that's okay
the key is doing it more frequently and
so during the pandemic i probably could
have used a better trigger what's
something that happens at least once a
month to you yeah that will trigger that
simple behavior of decluttering the the
camera roll here's one other thing i do
because the best way to to avoid the
clutter is to not bring it home in the
first place now that is especially true
with
our phones because it's so easy to
clutter them with photos so i learned
this from my friend our friend adam
dressler who's a photographer and he was
talking about going to
um
a
physical film which jordan knows all
about jordan does a lot of physical
pictures in fact he was showing ella he
let her take a few
film pictures the other day with his
film camera and she wanted to see the
picture right afterward and didn't
realize like oh i
have to get it printed out and all of
these other things right
and in in that experience
she realized that you have to be very
deliberate about the photos you can't
just snap snap snap snap snap because
you'll run out of photos very quickly
right
and so last night when i was at the
davinci thing it was snapping the one
photo it's
treating digital photos as though they
are
film photos now that causes all kinds of
problems sometimes my thumb or finger
will end up in the picture
now that's just a beautiful part of the
of the process or maybe the the
picture's blurry okay but now i've in a
way it almost enhances it because i wait
around it makes me intentional because
if i have unlimited photos on my phone
which i essentially do i can just be
there the whole time
taking pictures the whole night but if
it's i can only take one picture tonight
man i better be one i better be
intentional with the one bullet i have
because i can't i can't do more than one
yeah in a way that is also freeing it's
a freeing boundary yeah i uh my trigger
is
when i take like i've did my mom's in
town and my little niece and we'll take
like a selfie
and i'll do like i don't know two or
three of the same thing yeah and then i
just my trigger is to go in right away
and delete any duplicates okay so that
way i avoid duplicates in the future so
that's another thing you do too just uh
what what is it what do you what do you
call it you like clean as you go along
yeah it makes it way easier than if you
just like let it all build up that's
right yeah yeah because at some point
you don't realize that oh crap
i'm a year in two years in a decade in
my camera roll is just
a hoarder's paradise
or a hoarder's nightmare really did you
enjoy this video if so you can listen to
full episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free